I bet being ready to be friends if we  need another stain did you know that was  coming  man I'm just trying to stay positive I'm  engaged my marriage is all messed up  because of craziness cuz I'm not I'm not  a part of nothing crazy I'm trying to  walk down a good path my fiancee trippin  it's all bad in my world and that ain't  cool so you're not happy don't put me a  part of nothing that's weird that don't  make no sense you know what I'm sayin I  can I grow up  why weren't you in that bed I was  another one what did you think of the  video I loved it man  we need Kanye we need more Kanye's I  didn't know that he was going home drop  that drop that video you know even even  with me and him work on my album you  know like I don't even know like how I  had becoming like he'd be happening his  hair and he's just before you know it  like whoop there it is  what'd you think of the paint is being  what would you win not that famous